[Music]
our deep tribute to the
hard-working people of the Cerro Rico de Potosí
this rich Hill that for more than five
centuries, more than 500 years, has given
wealth to the world has given sources of
work our deep tribute to
these men who work day and night
to  give light to the country for this
excessive ambition of the world
Life
[Music]
of the content
This is
[Music]
Good morning Bon appetit friends Where
can I find Dynamite
here thanks
Dynamite coke
This is the dynamite is Dynamite how
does this Dynamite work
[Music]
and here  it turns on
I need alcohol also
96 degrees 96 degrees
really
for the pachamama
[Music]
very strong
to your liking very strong
yes [
Music] you
have to mix it
[Music]
it's very weak
You drink it I'm not
[Laughter]
already thanks to  you thank you
[Music]
Potosí is capitals
from Spanish [
Music]
after some two hands two hands
the uncle is the protective owner that we have
in the mine he is a God everything in here
belongs to the uncle So we have to
tell him Thank you also for  because it
gives us protection security gives us minerals
so a clear God is a God but
he is an Andean God he gives the beer to the uncle a prize
And the dynamite is for the uncle also that
more for the miners the uncle already has a
big dynamite there yes
[Applause]
alcohol thank you
because you have an erect penis uncle
machismo
machismo is here there are no women who
work women work only outside
the mine so introduce machismo is
a world of pure men
[Music]
many years ago with the Spanish
they worked with good quality silver, a
good amount and they removed
the trunk of the tree as we say and left
the branches And that We have already worked but
now There is very little money
[Music]
hard work Yes yes it is very hard Yes but
always We try to  be a little
happy Yes because it's a job
the miner Talk to me the you call calips to
make it a long Day
[Music] [
Music]
many people sometimes say no poor miner
How sad the miner must go to the mine
that's what  I was thinking I'm not
anymore no I'm not going to jail I
'm not going to a funeral either
So there's no reason to go to the
sad mine we
even see it as something more fun
Also sometimes it's not necessary for them
to work many days but they prefer
to be in the mine than to be in your own
houses
that's for the notes
[Music] [
Music]
health
for you life is a party
for new friendship
[Music]
If Life
tangerines
what other fruit can someone
who likes  He has lung problems
Okay,
thank you very much,
Good morning anyway
[Applause]
Good morning
How did you wake up
after some fruits
What fruit do you like?
I bring apples, tangerines and bananas,
the three of them
have a bad cough,
the mine's sickness is
deep in the dust,
that is, what  covered ready but they can't
get out
about five steps I'm already tired yes it's hard for him
to walk also you can't
you can't change
the agitation the breath is short
it's short that's why we
can't even talk when we
make an effort we talk the same shield that
evil of me
aquatic this  institution the truth is not
useful for here the truth so
the truth
old man I have not made die here he
said dead
Why Why that old man
I swear to God
nurse for me
I swear to God he has not done
The Old Man Who said nothing
there let's leave it  He's
there, my old man, take
care of yourself
[Music] He
has her hidden there
because we're sorry
to show that we don't see him Because we're
sorry Because we started to cry so
we hide him
and how he died he didn't die by
accident
he met his dad  no no I
was just waiting
for 5 months
papa
está tu papá
papi
[Music]
nning important One For Margarita
today with The Last of husband
[Music]
and get a Life
a little heart to the soul
so that the hermitage may rest in peace and
save her  Right hand of the Lord,
blessed soul, may he rest in peace, Eduardo.
almighty father lord
jesus christ
there is a little shop rest in peace i
received this prayer our father who
art in heaven hallowed be your
name your kingdom come your will be done
on earth as it is in heaven i
beg you to forgive these
blessed souls and save them  to his right hand
free him from everything that is punishable
these blessed souls take away his
spirit that is in his accident in the
mine that he has had
hold him to your right hand these
blessed souls forgive him
[Music]
Glory to the father Glory to the son Glory to the
Holy Spirit
as it was in the beginning now and always forever
and ever amen
God will forgive you of all your sins
as you have forgiven your family
shock bank bank for the bank because
bank talla vancumarico bank the nine
departments Bolivia bank
foreign bank factory bank  bills
dollar factory Euro bolivian
Argentine peso real guaraní
for them India endis Mansion
[Music]
Story
thank you thank you
carefully
don't drop it
thank you
now well
here we are
a special place
of who are those skulls no good they are
supposed to be  of the friars who
ceased to exist, well past centuries,
Spanish friars of course, you can touch it or you
can't and what was the purpose of
the Augustinian friars, as well as
the other religious orders, to evangelize
the mitayos that were brought from
different places in South America  South
they said Thank God we have
found so much wealth we have to
thank him and build a
temple another temple and so on
the altars in each of the temples
had silver racks the chalices the
ciboria
the Christs
[Music]
it is said and  this for sure Perhaps the
fact that
so much silver
extracted from the Cerro Rico in Potosí and
later
converted into metal and coins with that
silver could have built a
silver bridge from Potosí to Spain
So one can already imagine Not the
amount of silver that  It was exploited just the same, it
is said that with the bones and
human remains of the mitayos
another bridge could have been built from
Potosí to Spain.
by man
[Music]
many people in the world
are not interested in
nature they are not interested in
people they are not interested in the community
only they are going to think
money millions power the moment
So the thought we have here
is it is different  For example, there is
Cerro Rico
and this place where we are now is
called Cerro Chico and
our parents and grandparents many years
ago said that it was forbidden to touch this
small mountain.
work and they haven't touched now
we have fewer minerals on this mountain
but we are already working on this
small mountain that boy
no no no we don't have to take care we have to
take care
[Music]
waters in Chile In The High Store and
South American
[Music]
[  Music]
This is also to show the rest
of the world that in Chile, if we can, it's a
great icon and it's an effort
by everyone, from the oldest to the youngest,
you're in love from the tower.
that is our
[Music]
we had a jump because
pinochet threw out the question of
macroeconomics and of the economy
sierraja tabla, that is, everything has to be
based on profit and nothing more, there is no
social issue  There is no issue of Education or
anything, those who want education should
pay for it if they have health, they should pay for it And they think
they have done a favor by implementing
Pinochet capitalism
by killing people
How is his family now he
was an ordinary employee and
now a  of the great fortunes of Chile
less
[Music]
September 13, 1973 the
military junta controls the country general
pinochet presides over the government army general
Augusto pinochet was
appointed president of the military junta
that commands the destinies of the nation
since last Tuesday at  being
removed from the
Marxist government of Salvador Allende
is that many versions
say that he says that he said
that he committed suicide and others that
deep down they did kill him but
your mother is not there yet I don't know
if she will have arrived or not but
immediately
all your  homework everything with your homework
all homework
and you don't have to watch much television this you do
n't have to learn television to
this
trouble
from Baker to
schooly Times for Time with the Kids with
jobs
coming maximum There is your mom
says so here you have to  There is no father to
pick up the children, there is no mother who has
time,
usually the children are alone
here all day, that is, what I do is
that my father goes and that me and my children
find me here is already something nice because
the  offices work until 7 in the
evening
[Music]
the children look for something to distract
their minds that happens that is the
main problem I think the
parents have and how to solve that
is complicated because if I'm never there And
the only thing they do  It is to send the children
to the psychologist and prescribe pills and other
things.
You have to take the medicine at most, son,
take a little, a little, a little,
Grandfather's Train, a
little, no, not like that.
He says that I'm not with them I get
super anguish it's you when he was
born many things came together
so I got depressed I dedicated myself I tried to
be better for my children because
imagine if one collapses And the good thing
is that I have my dad here Like this  that this is
a fundamental support for me in my
life in my daily life
Yes everything will be fine Yes yes I know that
everyone everyone will always be
fine when one is with God always
[Music]
dies young after jumping from a tower  At the
Costanera Center, the person circumvented
security controls and jumped from the
27th floor of the shopping center, according to
police officers, the subject had a Canvas
that called for peace and love
Two suicides in one week On Wednesday,
a similar case occurred in the
shopping center when  a woman jumped at
12:50 from one of the floors of the
Mall where an attempt was made to resuscitate her
for 40 minutes without any results, it
gives me the impression that because of the type of
canvases the young man was carrying and the phrase
he said to the  At the end of the events, the
Costanera Center had some kind of
symbology for him that led him to
commit these acts. The case is already
before the Eastern Metropolitan Prosecutor's Office.
I saw I saw people jump a
young man who jumped from outside the
cornice and people who jumped inside
too and I saw the young man when he was
protesting when he was
up there for two hours threatening to throw himself what did
he say
capitalism against consumerism
that was what he was demanding he was protesting for a with an
alliance that I know he put it on his
body
he feels  You know that capital has not
harmed Mental Health in Chile,
I think so.
What happens is that I believe that here the
social classes are very marked,
the poor, very poor and rich, very rich,
here it is very difficult to access what a
good  health a good education for the
children they take care of them they don't
totally forget it costs a lot that
treats Everything is paid here Everything is expensive and
what is public is bad
[Music]
WHO report says that 5% of
Chileans have depression the Ministry
says  that only 2% of the
health budget is for these ills when the
ideal is 5 or
6%.  Life in Chile is not very easy.
People spend all their time working
in Transantiago to pay bills,
over-indebtedness, the fact that
kindergartens and schools have hours that
do not coincide with the parents' work
are factors that affect
depression
[  Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but pathological
I knew that one of the concerns that
many people have is the debts
they have, they say that one is born with debts
until one dies with debts because I
never finished paying it off, all the people
are bitter about it.  the street and that
generates debts, not being able to do what
one wants Simply because they are
in debt and not even able to do it until they go on
vacation
because they have to
save a lot of money during the year to
be able to go out and sometimes to go on
vacation there is  to go into debt
to get out
[Music]
because we are a student we already
have to in some other way because
the studies Unfortunately they are very
expensive we are talking about millions and the
cadet charges us later he takes out all the
eyes we have and we did not invent it
in parallel the forest you finished
studying You already paid your debts
you haven't stopped laughing
and at one o'clock at two o'clock loud laughter at
three o'clock [
Applause] [
Laughter] [
Music]
from Argentina
[Music]
José María
Legend
and satu was doing Every good
[Music]
like To  talk about something else at
like to find you happiness
[Music]
this is our volcano
Where it is with snow
is the volcano and it's called copahue and where
knowledge is born and what it teaches you
How to be a person because in the
indigenous world Or in  the mapuche world the
special one is not born a person but
becomes a person and how the volcano transmits
that wisdom through the stove The
stove the transmitter of
which does not make many things known
in knowledge But how does
the volcano communicate with The stove through
the  smoke the smoke Yes the volcano smokes
and The stove smokes
is almost a classic image of an
indigenous person with the smoke with the rag and
making signs and clear language with
the smoke That's right It still exists It still
exists Here is one of the sectors
less western intervention
[Music]
Santiago
It was me José María
[Music]
the [ __ ] [
Music]
Desire for a Mother Life boys girls
begin to have dreams of the other
culture modern culture and from there
the boy goes frustrated  he gets frustrated
because he doesn't reach modern life because
of course because modern life, what they
promised him, often gets stuck
because in the end they realize that it's
a bubble
of things and in the end it's not for the
Mapuches
that if you study
primary secondary education and
university I am going to become an
important person in life I am going to become I am going to
belong to this society
and one is a professional but you cannot
function in your own community
here I cannot become a
lawyer
medical engineer because the work is outside
Santiago
from there the frustration of
young people begins and those boys in the end do not get
better in the end they commit suicide
and it has touched me very closely I
lost my eldest son
he looks dirty
he hung from one to one in a house
at 17  years
and now it's been 10 years,
10 years ago but it still hurts, it never
went away
I'm sorry
Since that time I decided to work with
young people with the children
So I don't want other parents to happen
in that situation
your son felt frustrated frustrated he
didn't feel capable
yes,
your mom is still sad too
[Music]
what brings you more happiness in
your life I listen to music all day I sing
in the car I greet the people who
are next to the car I dance with those who
are next to any  craziness that
comes to mind I do it and the shame doesn't matter
[Music]
Happiness is all I do with
some sense because if not not if I don't
do it with sense it's because I don't value
anything
the towel is going to dry me
completely dry  everything for me must be
valued and with that the way in which
I find happiness
what causes me the most happiness is
hearing my two daughters laugh and watching them
play and the best of all is in the
mornings because they are always smiling
a barbecue  With my friends in the countryside
with a good Chilean wine loin vetoed or
puntapicana and hopefully the sword will be
turned around for a long time inside
the Coal I
love to sing a lot I love to sing I am
[Music]
my daughter makes me very happy I laugh with
she's funny all day she's
funny my pets
are also very fun in the group
together
[Music] do you
think your mom is happy I think she
is very happy
I think she's already having a great time you
have debts No I don't have debts
one of  the few Chileans So yes I
am organized with with my money I am in
debt I would tell you I always think it might
be better
with whom with your parents or with me with a
partner with friends
with your daughter also
a long long time the truth
[Music]
What happens when there is  sadness What happens
when there is anguish What happens when there is a
lack of hope in our lives many
times that depressions those sadnesses of
the heart those sadnesses of the soul are
what make us truly be
dead a person who no longer
finds meaning in life is a
true sound of  a person who is
walking like a living dead the
church seeks and understands that this
solution is precisely in what
Christ gives us
[Music] [
Music]
It's
anointed with oil the healing of all
your physical, emotional and
spiritual illnesses by the doctor of  souls
and bodies so that you always have
good thoughts so that you can
always see the will of God in your life
your hands so that with your hands
you can do the will of God man
of the father of the son on the other hand your
hands and the spirit  holy amen
[Music]
Tierra del Fuego in Argentina you
can't see anything but
the sea the mountains the weather
good beer
we are full
[Music] [Music
] [
Music] I
've been fishing crab for almost 30 years
and it doesn't seem to have much
competition  because I don't see other
fishermen, luckily we don't speak too
loudly, we
are still very few here So we
practically have the channel for a few
at other times of the year
as we have friends from Chile there,
they bring many boats and the catch
that would be ours is taken away  They
over there call the Chileans friends they
are neighbors they are neighbors they are neighbors
[Music]
decape every day
origin Argentina [
Music] [
Music]
from the north of Argentina 600 kilometers
long road
Argentina chile Argentina chile
Argentina chile  Argentina
Hello
And well they are of me to the
months to get here
[Music]
before I right here I
Always
Fast Plains
[Music] [
Music]
the world
[Music]
Here I have many people who are from Mexico or
Brazilian Colombians
also working in USA  And in other places,
all the Mexican Latinos
realized that there was work here and I think that
Ushuaia is characterized by that as
a place that is full of people who
are not from Ushuaia or Tierra del Fuego Not
if you talk to anyone
It's rare to find someone from here but
a Nick as they say he was
born and raised in blue So the exact born and
created
[Music] [
Music]
Hello
How are you I
wanted to ask something about
this With what dream did you come here
president of the  neighborhood Ah the president
of the neighborhood Ah how is
the mayoress the mayoress
and they elected you as president
And what dream did you bring when you came
here
and to have our own little house that we already
achieved Yes but well the little house
Yes something like that but a little better but
well we are improving it little by little
yes yes of mother construction
and well not even stay Here it is My old age
with him with him Yes he brought me from my
province the man of his dreams Yes and
improving our life having a better life
means having more money and well
yes it could be a little more money yes
but to help the family in this
case to help the children
the puppy was part of his dream also
of my 18 year old son it was his dream
when we rented he wanted a dog he
didn't want  siempre un perrito
[Music]
la tierra del fuego sostenible
population [
Music]
you know Why askey [
everybody want to the car
[Music]
What's like a destructional
a level of water more or less  of 20 and does not
step on it with the hand because with the hand it
cuts quickly the hand is cut pulling
Uh-huh instead of the paw it takes more
sticking
the hand
[Music]
these are special traps for beavers
they are for fox but to
use it
and all this disaster  The Beaver made it
clear, it
floods the earth and from the tongue it dries up,
eats, eats, it cuts, and that keeps
throwing it where it makes the dam.
water is to
see danger and the water goes for
protection so no animal can be
found out there it gets flat it gets
flat and nothing like that
but it's a teacher
[Music]
Thank you very much [
Music]
the theory of evolution
of evolution
in the forest alone alone  pilot it alone in
a place where there is nothing
in something you have to believe
at night you learn to pray as
a friend tells me in the trench in the hospital there
is no atheist
I think it is a necessity of the
human being and at the same time it is good that people
believe in something so that it is not so more
evil than
people are people changed with
economic growth here if you
have nothing and one fine day you find
that you have a good house a good
truck and you for your thinking have the
truck the house money from the bank that
's what you are if they take that away from you that's
understood the idea
the only thing that they will never steal from you
is what you will see they
will never steal from you what you know, that
is  the people I know, that
is, say that they were who came here with
little and
made money, the one who has nothing in his
head changed, the one who has nothing
here changed, and the one who has something here did not
change,
good to fix girlfriend and such
natural
very good
a little hard because it has never been
big you saw but it was cooked a lot it was
cooked well yes it
bothers you if I tell you that you have a certain
physical resemblance to a Beaver
no don't bother
fat I am Skinny how disappeared Yes
but you have the tail
to have both  teeth below
and this week fly no teeth do
you like it Tell me the truth It's good yes
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
tierra del fuego
[Music]
of the national lottery lottery draw
2098 held today four
twenty-eight zero zero five
one
of three million
at 32 49 10 and nothing else
that's the meat
well and I'll give you the meat that 49 10
pesos
this would be just 100 pesos
each number has a meaning
that I know of there you go down the street
see a person who  the fall is
the 56
the dream so you dreamed of meat
then the meat means 49 And
last night you dreamed of barbecue Oh that was Yes
then I say I'll leave you this morning
And what happened in the dream of the barbecue and well
we were with all the  family there are some
friends it will be that all Argentines
dream of roasts and well the roast and the
mate
is drunk and eaten in Argentina
this 200 of 20 per kilo
So to eat roast you have to
think about it now
the lotus
[Music]
at this time Argentina
[Music] He
likes it I don't know where to see I've never
bought a Lamb,
you look at me,
it's so chubby
11 kilos 800 How much does a kilo cost
130 pesos
Take it
gypsies
because
the way you dress like you speak banana
[Music]
you gypsy
but  no no I don't like it
and the Bolivians yes I don't know that
very hard-working people in Bolivian It's not
true like all good
but they are very hard-working people and the
Argentinian How is the Argentinian is lazy
[Laughter]
So I'm going to
Argentina
[Music]
my family  who is working here
welcome here This is the field of the
traditionalist association of Home
folklore this good This was founded in
2005 this this previous that they gave us
three hectares that was founded to
preserve Argentine traditions that
is to instill values ​​in the
children well This  It is passing from
generation to generation
But why do you want
traditions to be maintained and because here it
is like that it is maintained so that it does not
get lost and does not die But why can't
you die, no and never you can't
die
from mate
and organization out brutal
a gaucho Yes and if you are a gaucho your
wife is a gaucha china cauchina china
china yes and your son
Yes I speak of beans
[Music]
n American
on Tierra del Fuego all The Reason
[Music]
it this nostalgia
handsome
good
the horse
rich health
health
[Music]